how bad is the economy right now i mean
what is the price of gas
i saw california it was uh six on
average
it's 696 near where i live average u.s
let's see four 696
even in your neighborhood and like a
little closer to downtown but yeah it's
really good
yeah
man yeah but it's about four
four six four nine national average is
4.2
do you have the cold bear bit
let's get the cold bear bit up about i
wonder if we can play can we play it
what's he doing why can't we play it uh
because it's copyright of what is that
cbs or yeah they they understand we got
an arrangement with them
i do i got an arrangement with viacom um
i can
i'm i'm good
they don't
no colbert where he tells everybody to
go buy a tesla oh that's right
i'll tell you what i will never complain
about a destination wedding again
russia has been hit with a series of
crippling sanctions and it looks like
there's more to come because the us
and its european allies are now
discussing banning imports of russian
oil take that putin we're not going to
buy our gas from a war criminal we're
going to buy it from the good guys saudi
arabia
but
it's going to cost
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america had an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two no i'm willing to
pay
it's important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
right now people all over the world are
trying to find inventive ways to help
ordinary
yes so i mean you know i i you know i
get it the saudi joke's pretty funny but
you know telling people you can spend
another dollar or two on a gallon of gas
and you know you know that's not helping
right i don't think that really warms
the hearts of
people in this country who are destitute
makes you furious watching yeah it makes
you angry uh watching it because people
are suffering already
and i don't think that there's a real
good
you know a clean conscience i mean
clean conscience
what are we doing in like yemen yeah
like
pull up yemen by the way see what's
going on over in yemen
just hit google image yemen already
yeah
go to the third photo over there
yeah what's that
what happened there
that looks like a scene out of the bible
what's going on over there that seems to
be a problem too
but nobody's talking about a dollar to
uh gas for yemen jesus saudi arabia has
been uh bombing yemen
with american money
and american equipment for years they've
been carrying out what essentially
amounts to a genocide in yemen
and
this is why people hate late night
comedy they hate
performative activism they hate all this
stuff because they know
they they genuinely
know that it's fake
and that it's very selective
and that it only you know it's a
zeitgeist thing it's the in thing to do
and they're going to have a thing on the
academy awards and i'm not saying that
the ukraine is not something that
you should you should feel horrible
about and notice but saying well you
could have a clean conscience you should
never with the things this government's
done you should never go to bed with a
clean conscience
if you're paying attention if you've
read a book no clean conscience at all
um
amy schumer said against zalinski on the
show we talked about this on the patreon
we're not going to go over it again
but the oscars has said no to that
they've said no which is sad
because i wanted to see that same i
wanted to see zielinski on the academy
awards doing a comedy bit with amy
schumer
while his country's being
attacked
i think that'd be a good use of his time
to uh be on the academy awards
making
doing a bit
about the the shelling of the country
what if zilinski really came on and they
just did some
like
bit
that just didn't land
about
now
the nazis in the ukraine
because now they're and they're taping
people that are looting and stuff to
things and people are going look at them
they're doing the wrong thing i mean by
the way i mean all the things america's
done with you know
i mean taping people to a poll is not
even the least of it
but they are taping uh people you know
it's martial law over there it's not
great
so if they think somebody is alluding or
something
they're taping them to a poll
and this has made people very
uncomfortable
that are
watching this
trying to figure out
you know
what our role should be
vigilante punishment spreads into
ukraine
and a lot of people
that are doling out these punishments
are this azoff battalion of nazis
um
but they're not the bad not they're not
like the nazis like that or like the
charlottesville like they're these are
like
there's hot different kinds of not like
there's like different kinds of nazis
and people don't realize this and like
these nazis are in
when a nazi is hot in this business
they're hot
let's get real
when a nazi is heat
in the entertainment business they got
heat
it's a business about heat
not about talent per se but it's about
heat
and when you're hot you're hot
and right now the azov battalion is
hot
we like them they're in
we want to know more
we
like it they're patriotic they're
standing up to putin
um so
they're not
the nazis that are out there's nazis
that are out
that we we say they're not marketable
and let's get them off social
let's get him off social media let's put
him in the back of the room
not a fan of those nazis but then there
are nazis uh
they're a little more cinematic
it's more exciting they're more exciting
the industry kids they're industry kids
they're we hand picked them they're
selected you've been selected
as of battalion
they're the nazis of the moment
they're the nazis of the moment
and here's the deal
and this is i'm going to this is going
to come out wrong
i'm trying to figure out how to say it
and remain
with the ability to communicate with
large numbers of people
but here's what i'll say
in every now and then
you need
a cool
group of nazis
every now and then
not a lot you don't want to overdo it
but every now and then
you need to overlook some [ __ ]
and just elevate
a cool
group of nazis
because
hey
it's punk rock
it's punk rock
and we forget about that
we forgot we've gotten soft
but
now do you they just the the hazop nazi
guy literally just
was broadcast on cnn and they had them
yeah yeah they had him on
they had him on
let's see here they had him on they had
him on to make his case mm-hmm
malcolm nance on twitter says there's no
nazis left in the asap it's telling that
we've they've been rid of all nazis well
that's disappointing isn't it yeah
and
here's what i say about that
i don't believe that
but maybe after this happens the azo
battalion's hearts will be warmed
by amy schumer yeah what if amy schumer
convinces the azoff battalion
to stop being nazis
and start
clearing the space
by accepting
lgbtq
ia2
people into their brigade
perhaps
so now we have the a's of the head of
the azoff battalion here yeah his name
is dennis uh
dennis i'm trying to pronounce don't
even try
don't even try with the names
here's the clip here now cnn has spoken
with a commander a ukrainian military
commander who's been defending the city
from the siege
take a listen to what he sent us a day
ago
people are cooking food in the streets
risking their lives is under their
container let me be honest
i get a nazi vibe
if it was just based on vibes
if it was just based on vibes
i get a nazi vibe
not saying what what the defending of
the city is bad
not saying you don't have to make
alliances with people that are nutty
but i get a little bit of a nazi vibe
from this gentleman
now i could be wrong
let's see what he has to say
as the temperature is minus five degrees
celsius in the street killing the
civilian the amount of weak sims growth
every day now it is uh more than three
thousand but nobody knows the exact
amount because people are buried
together in the same dump with no names
many bodies are just outside the streets
without being buried some of people are
under the ruined buildings buried alive
ukrainian army is trying to help
civilians with food and water but it's
not enough
there is no safety places for people in
mariupol the missiles of the enemy are
attacking the houses and people are
dying in their beds
it's a horrible situation
um
that needs to end
truly i mean there you know this can't
this is it this has to end
we have to figure a way out of this
uh
and you know
you know i i don't want to you know we
can't split hairs here about you know
yeah we got there's some nazis there
that are
they're doing the work
they put their head down
they're doing the work
the nazis were very bad but they were
they weren't inefficient
so if you could get the nazis to do
things you want them to do
like what about a nazi run steakhouse be
great
right
so we could focus nazis on
other things
we're doing the right thing here yeah